うーん、うーん、大丈夫、大丈夫、人がちぼうからこんにちは、小刻みに動き始めているようです。 岡からこんにちは神戸からこんにちは今日は高低アクセントと発音について少しお話しますが、高低アクセントと発音は、主に大阪で使用されている高低アクセントとは根本的に異なります。 標準的な日本語よりも良いので、そこに住んでいる人には関係ありませんが、シアトルからこんにちは、シアトルから来ました。私は眠りにつくと思っていましたが、大丈夫ではないと思います。 ええと、私たちが推奨するよりも高いので、2500のストリームビットレートを使用することをお勧めします。 私が今日話したいと思った最初のことのどれも、私が標準的な日本のトホクにしたかった最初のこと、そして私は多くの人が私として質問をすることができると思うので、ライブの設定でこれをやってみたいと思いました 一部の人にとってはるかに有益なことを説明しているので、パトレオンでもこれらすべてを教えていますが、ここでもライブで物事を明確にすることができるので、それは一種の楽しい新しいものになると思いました やるべきことですが、今日のトピックは動詞の高低アクセントです。日本語を知らない人にとっては高低アクセント言語です。つまり、英語とは異なり、英語は強勢アクセント言語であり、単語のアクセントの位置を意味します。 アクセントがどのように言われるかは、その単語のその音節に与える力の量とパンチの種類によって決まります。したがって、明日を英語で言うと、少し誇張されていますが、明日はマビットが もっと大きくして言った 他の音節よりもわずかに高いピッチですが、ピッチは他の音節よりも大きく、力強く言ってみた結果です。英語のアクセントはこのようになりますが、日本語のアクセントを作ると 力の種類ではなく、ピッチだけの問題なので、力の量も増えることがありますが、日本語の主な違いは、少なくとも英語と比べてピッチが 日本語にはアクセントのない単語がたくさんあるので、単語のアクセントやアクセントの欠如を決定するのは、日本語の経済学の単語を言うと、最初のqueが他のビットよりも高いかどうかです。 今日は動詞を取り上げるつもりなので、日本語で食べるという言葉が良い例かもしれません。これが明日のような言葉と違うのは、明日はそれだと言うときです。
sは他の2つの音節よりも長くて大きいですが、日本語では他の2つの音節よりもそれほど大きくも長くもありません。一般的に言えば、高低アクセントであるため、英語を母国語とする人がしがちなことの1つは、識別できることです。 多くの単語の高低アクセントを聞きますが、特定の単語の高低アクセントを再現しようとすると、強勢のアクセントであるかのように言う傾向があるため、少し誇張されたタブを言うのではなく、それは1つの良いことです 高低アクセントの勉強を始めたばかりなのかどうかを知っておく必要がありますが、今日私が取り上げたかった本当の重要なことはそれです。これは私がそれを知ったときの一種のゲームチェンジャーでした。 あなたが英語を母国語とする場合、または[音楽]が高低アクセント言語である言語の母国語を話す場合、スペイン語も高低アクセント言語であると私は信じています。フランス語についてはよくわかりません。 ええと、ドイツ語も強勢アクセント言語だと思いますが、強勢アクセント言語のバックグラウンドを持っている場合は、日本語の特定の高低アクセントパターンを理解できますが、日本語のすべての高低アクセントパターンを理解できるわけではありません。 聞こえない高低アクセントパターンではなく、聞こえる高低アクセントパターンですべての日本語の単語を言う傾向があるので、これが本当に良い例であるとはどういう意味ですか？ 日本語で教えるための単語今、私たちは日本語で食べるための単語について話しましたが、それは低高低低高低です。ほとんどのネイティブ英語話者ネイティブ英語スペイン語とドイツ語話者はこのパターンを再び聞くことができます。 明日のストレスアクセントパターンと少し似ているように聞こえますが、少しだけ力と長さがありますが、類似点があります。 うーん、うーん、よく似ていますが、日本語で教えるような言葉があると、英語のネイティブスピーカーとスペイン語のネイティブスピーカーとドイツ語のスピーカーは、アクセントがあるかのように言う傾向があります。 なぜなら、ネイティブの英語話者またはネイティブのストレスアクセント言語の話者として、私たちは言語のすべての単語にストレスまたはある種のアクセントを付けたいと思う傾向があるからです。 特に、私たちはすべての日本語の単語をアクセントのあるすべての日本語の動詞と言う傾向がありますが、アクセントのない日本語の動詞はたくさんあります。
oそれは一種のフラットであり、これが実際に多くの日本人教師が日本語がフラットであると言う理由です。 単語にはアクセントがあります。日本人の多くのネイティブの日本人教師と多くの非ネイティブの日本人教師も、日本語の高低アクセントを生徒に説明するための優れたフレームワークを持っておらず、生徒に本物の力強い言葉の使用をやめさせたいと考えています。 自国語の高低アクセントパターンを日本語で強調するので、この種の包括的ステートメントを使用します。これもまた、よりフラットな方法で話します。日本語はフラットであるため、一部の単語には良いアドバイスですが、他の単語には本当に悪いアドバイスですが、すばらしい この例は、日本語の開閉の言葉です。もう一度ドアを閉めたい場合のように、日本語の服の言葉は、ネイティブの英語話者がそのダウンステップを聞くことができます。 その動詞の対応物はとても開いていますええと、高低アクセントのパターンなしでそれを綴るつもりです私たちはそれがケルであるべきだと思います私たちはシメル大丈夫だと思います 高低アクセントがまったくない、または動詞にアクセントがないのは、日本語の動詞の例の1つではないので、これは一種の最初のものです。 日本語の動詞と高低アクセントに関して非常に重要なことは、日本語の動詞の動詞が何十、何十、何百もあることを認識することは本当に本当に有益です。 それらの中にアクセントがあり、あなたがネイティブの英語を話す人なら、あなたがすぐに改善できることを認識することを学ぶことができれば、それらの多くはアクセントを持っていなくても、おそらくアクセント付きの日本語の動詞の圧倒的多数を言っているでしょう あなたの習慣の多くはあなたがあなたがyabathonが影から飛び出すのを待っていることをあなたが知らないかもしれない悪い習慣です 高低アクセントは、できるだけネイティブに聞こえたい場合に重要であるため、学習者に委ねられます。ネイティブの英語を話さない場合は、多くのネイティブの日本語を話すため、勉強することが非常に重要であると強く信じています。 これはもちろんあなたの第二言語だと思いますが、多くの人は良い音を出すことはできません。多くの人は、いわば特定のレベルのようにしか到達できない非ネイティブスピーカーとして考えられていると思いますが 可能な限り最高のレベルを目指して努力し、可能な限りネイティブに近づきたいのであれば、勉強することは絶対に重要だと思いますが、自分の主張を理解したいだけなら、勉強することは絶対に重要ではありません。 それは多くの人が心配していることですええとええと私はあなたのフーディーを愛しているのを見てみましょう ピッチの変化に気付くのは難しく、それらの変化をうまく再現するのはさらに難しいです。これは、最近の日本語のumコメディックビデオでカバーしようとしたものです。これは、日本語の「花」と「鼻」の違いです。 日本人のネイティブの人にこのええと尋ねると、その人の彼らは日本の給料や訓練のように経験していません、そして圧倒的多数の状況で圧倒的多数の時間彼らはハナと言うでしょうああ彼らは同じですが正しい これに対する答えは、実際には、それらが分離して設定されている場合は同じですが、次の粒子でそれらを言うと同じではありません。 鼻と花を単独で言うと同じですが、次の助詞で言うと完成です。 鼻が違うのは花が花で、日本人のネイティブスピーカーは無意識のうちにこれをやっています。外国人の日本語を聞いていると、日本人のネイティブスピーカーがつまずくようなものです。 花について説明していると言ったら、それは美しい鼻だと言っているように聞こえます。コンテキストだけがスーパーチャットであるという状況がたくさんあることを知っています。本当にありがとうございます。 ありがとうございます。ブレークとブレークのコンテキストが重要であると思います。はい、いいえ。つまり、プロトストリークがそこに書き込んだものをブレークしてブレークすると、周囲の単語に関係なくまったく同じように発音されます。 正しく壊れますが、日本語での差別化要因の1つは、多くの状況で粒子が付着する方法であるため、花や鼻がうつ伏せになっているわけではありません。 同じように発音しますが、これら2つの単語を単独で言う場合にのみ同じ発音になりますが、追加のコンテキストなしで1つの単語として花だけを言う状況の数は非常に限られており、通常は次のようになります。 ある種の文脈で、もしそうなら、ある種の文脈でそれを説明しようとしているのなら、正しいピッチの行為と正しい発音でそれを言ってみてください。 粒子も含めてまったく同じ発音ですが、日本語には粒子だけが違うという言葉がたくさんあるので、頑張っているのならまたやろうとしているのかどうかを知っておくことがとても重要だと思います 私の意見では、できるだけ日本語を上手に使うために、ええと、ここにもう1つの本当に良い例があります。神の単語は高から低の神と発音されますが、髪の単語は と私が信じる紙は両方とも低高低と発音され、粒子は低アクセントになっているので、本当に速いことを確認しましょう 紙も同じですええ神賀なので神と紙と髪の違いは高低アクセントですが紙と髪は高低アクセントも含めてまったく同じ発音なので高低アクセントが多いです 日本語には同音異義語がない、つまりまったく同じ発音の単語がたくさんあるので、日本語にはまったく同じ発音の単語がないという高低アクセントだけが違います。 いくつかのカップルのチャットええと、アジムはどうもありがとうございました3ドルのスーパーチャットフルカー私はこれが何の通貨かわかりませんが、それは20と言います。どうもありがとう、そしてええと インドからおはようございます40は、ルピーが何であるかわからないということですええと、通貨が何であるかはわかりませんが、本当にありがとうございます。 高いので、高くなりますええええと、誰かがええと、私もこれを入力できると思う単語を書いたのを見てみましょうが、これの単語は実際には本当に良い例なので、私はちょうど入力したことを置くつもりです 家に帰るという言葉を言うと、それは言葉の最初のビートの最初のモーラの種類にアクセントが付いていますが、変更するという言葉を言うと、それはフラットであり、それは実際にはカエルと同じです 英語を母国語とする人は、家に帰る動詞のように動詞が変わると言う傾向があります。たとえば、ここで言うと、これは本当に良い例のようです。これは、私が持っている二重の間違いのようなものです。 友達のように聞いてみたいと思ったら、過去に実際に言った 髪のスタイルを変えるとカミカエタと言うかもしれませんが、英語を母国語とする人は言う傾向がありますが、高低アクセントの点では、髪を変えたのではなく、神が家に帰ったように聞こえます。 良い例ええ、あなたはおそらく、髪を変えたと言うよりも自然なことでしょう。 パトレオンに関する10のレッスン基本的な音を再現するために基本をもっと練習するにはどうすればよいですか？高低アクセントの認識を向上させ、日本の4つの高低アクセントパターンを自然に再現する能力を向上させるためにできることがいくつかあります。 正しい発音をもう一度言うことができますか？ええ、それは私がそこにいくつかの例文を与えたことに依存しますが、間違った発音は 神は家に帰ったのですが、前に友人に言ったのですが、正しい発音はカミカイタに近いので、カミウムに続く粒子を取り出すと、これらの動詞も単語もどちらもありません 両方ともフラットで、粒子を入れると髪にアクセントがありますが、典型的なスピーチでは粒子を取り出すので、もう一度カミカイタまたはカミキタのようになります。 その動詞は最初にダウンステップを持っているので、それは注意すべきことですが、高低アクセントの発音の認識を再び向上させるために、あなたができる本当に良いことの1つは、まず最初に、できるだけ多くの日本語を聞くことです。 日本語の高低アクセントの基本を学んだ後、質問は大丈夫です。日本語の高低アクセントの基本をどのように学ぶのですか。公開されている20分のビデオのようなものだと思います。
e youtubeで、日本語の方言のアクセント101のようなタイトルだと思います。そのビデオでは、4つの基本的な日本語のアクセントのパターンを詳細に説明し、そのビデオを見ると、超高品質のネイティブ録音を含む一連の例の単語を示しました。 数回、私が言っていることを理解し、2、3か月かけて、日本語のスピーチを聞きながら、これら4つの異なるパターンを理解しようとすると、根本的にあなたのやり方が変わります。 日本語を聞くと、それだけでも時間の経過とともに徐々に日本語を話す方法が変わり始めますが、重要なことは、最初にその認識を取得し、それが適切なポイントに達したら、自分で録音を開始できるようにすることです。 同様に、最初はパターンを識別してネイティブスピーチでそれらを選択できるようになり、それからそれができるようになったら、おそらく3か月 将来的には、日本に何度も没頭した後、少なくとも6か月はもっとお勧めしたいのですが、その時点でできることは、このピッチアクセントができたので、自分で録音する前に自分で録音したことがない場合です。 初めてこれを行う場合、私はあなたがちょっと待っているようなものになることをほぼ保証できるので、私はこれらの言葉が間違っていると言っていますが、私はそれらを正しく言っていると思っていましたが、 高低アクセントのパターンで一言言っていると思っていたのですが、実際には別のパターンで言っていたので、間違って言っていることに気付く前に、録音で自分の言うことを実際に聞かなければなりませんでした。 あなたが実際に自分自身を録音しようとするそのステップを踏むなら、あなたはそれを拾うでしょうこれは私が録音しているときに私がそれをするたびに日本のコメディビデオを録音するたびにほぼ確実に起こるように 多くの場合、私は間違っていると言っていますが、少なくともビデオを録画するときは常に、少なくとも1回はまともだと思う方法で各行を言いますが、編集プロセスに入ると、通常は少なくとも それぞれのビデオで、私はその行を正しく言っていると思っていましたが、実際には少し間違っていますが、必ずしも高低アクセントのことではありませんが、通常は少なくとも何かがあり、自分自身を録音しない場合は、 高低アクセントと発音の認識ができたら、自分の日本語でできることがたくさんあるので、自分自身を不幸にします。それを適用しようとすると、大きなスーパーチャットがありました。ありがとうございます。方法がわかりません。
akitakiumoopsを読んでください。 よ シャドウイングをコーラスすることで本当に良いピッチアクセントを得ることができると思いますか？ それを行わないよりも100％優れており、高低アクセントの研究に関わるあらゆる努力は、ほとんどの場合と同じようにあなたを連れて行きます。それは、リターンを減らすことの問題であり、両対数のリズミカルな効果があるので、最初の努力は 高低アクセントに費やす最初の10時間のように、ゆっくりと時間と労力を費やすと、次の10時間で大きな違いが生じます。 大きな違いはありますが、次の10時間はそれほど大きくはありませんが、わずかに違いが少なくなります。 まず、ネイティブスピーチで高低アクセントを意識し、コーラスやシャドウイングを行うなど、さまざまなことで、これらの練習で大きな進歩を遂げることができますが、本当に良い高低アクセントとは何か、また、 これらの2つの演習だけで、可能な限り最高の高低アクセントを好きになることができます。これらは非常に効果的な演習になると思います。シャドウイングについて少し心配しているのは、シャドウイングしないよりも確かに優れているということです。 もしあなたが戻ってあなたが言葉を言った方法を聞いたり、あなたの発音についてのフィードバックを得たりしていないなら、あなたはあなたが実際に正しい方法で影を落としていたかどうかわからない、そして私は実際にこれが ユーチューブチャンネルを始めてから日本語がとても上手になった理由のひとつは、ユーチューブビデオを作るたびに悲惨になるからです。 私が言っていたことに気づかなかった私の日本語の小さなことの高低アクセントについてかなりの量を知っている私からのctフィードバックなので、追加のフィードバックの問題は、あなたがいる場合とは対照的に、大きな違いを生むことができると思います ただ言ってフィードバックを受け取らないので、自分で録音しているときにシャドウイングして、ピッチアクセントについてかなりの量を知っていれば、それらの録音を聞くことができますが、それに加えて、ネイティブスピーカーを見つけることができれば ペイチェックについて少し知っていますが、そうでない場合は、通常、イントネーションを言うか好きな場合は、イントネーションを修正するように依頼します。これは、日本人が高低アクセントであると考えているようなものです。実際には、完全ではありません。 別のことですが、それは大丈夫です。私がこのサービスを使用したことのないcotu io testのように、知覚リコールの生成をドリルできるサイトについてどう思いますか。 私はあなたの目標を達成するためにできるだけ多くのツールを使用することに全力を注いでいるので、ミニマルペアを知らない人のためにミニマルペアを表示するアンキフラッシュカードを使用するのが大好きです。
1つを除いてまったく同じ発音の単語は、花と鼻の両方が正しい例です。粒子を付けると、両方ともハナになりますが、同じ発音ではないためです。 異なる高低アクセントとパターンがあるので、もう一度知っていますが、花は花賀です。ミニマルペアの高低アクセントのアンキフラッシュカードのように使用する場合、それはあなたのええとを改善するための本当に良い方法です正しい高低アクセントパターンを識別する能力は何と言いますか？ 私のパトレオンにはいくつかのパトレオンコースがあり、以下の説明にリンクされています。このトピックに関するビデオがたくさんありますが、私のシリーズにも高低アクセントとアンキがいくつかあります。 いくつかのjusをデッキします 一般的な単語のページアクションを表示するだけで、最小限のペアピッチアクセントデッキがいくつかあると思いますが、ピッチアクセントパターンが異なることを除いて同じ2つの単語であるため、耳を傾ける必要があります。 彼らに聞いて、聞いたことに基づいて正しい高低アクセントパターンを選択してください。これは非常に優れたツールになると思います。そうですね、結び目に使用する高低アクセントがあるかどうかを見てみましょう。申し訳ありませんが、私の机は今おかしくなりそうです。 ちょっと待ってください。誰かが質問をしました。同じ発音ではありません。同じように発音されないので、花は花田と発音されますが、鼻は発音されるので重要です。 高低アクセントシリーズの一部であるフラッシュカードを誰でもうまくリンクできるので、月額10ドルの場合は、私のコースの一部です。 私がこれまでに作成したすべてのレッスンとそれらのデッキにすぐにアクセスできるので、それらのデッキのいくつかは、人々に支払いをしました。複数のデッキがありました。いくつかのデッキは、パトレオンで利用できるようにするために支払いました。
iiiはしませんでしたが、それらはすべてそのページにリストされており、それらのデッキを他のすべての人と共有するためにお金を払っている私の常連客にとっては本当に公平ではありません。 それでは、あーはしはしの場合があり、大阪では高低アクセントが反転していると思うので、これは本当に良い点です。日本語の高低アクセントのパターンが標準の日本語とは根本的に異なる日本語の方言がたくさんあります。 だから、大阪に住んでいるような人や、地域によって高低アクセントのパターンが違う人はどうしたらいいのかとよく聞かれますが、日本語のアクセントを勉強するのは無意味ではないでしょうか。 今すぐ両方の質問に答えます地域によって高低アクセントが違うので、高低アクセントを勉強するのは無意味だと言うのは間違いだと思います。その理由は、圧倒的に多くの場合、日本人のネイティブスピーカーがいるからです。 高低アクセントパターンの統一されたセットで話すので、標準的な日本語で圧倒的に話すか、西洋の方言の日本人のように、または私の住んでいる場所のように、または北部の方言の日本人のように、久州のように、カーンサイベンで圧倒的に話します。 ある方言から別の方言に切り替えるのと同じように、英語の発音や高低アクセントを勉強するのは無意味だと言っているようなものです。イギリス英語では一部の単語の言い方が異なり、私が話すのでこの点を説明するのは非常に簡単です。 私が突然このように上手に話し始めたら、今は標準的な英語で イギリス訛りのように、そしてすぐに通常の英語に戻ってからイギリス英語に戻ったそれは統一されていないので奇妙なことになるので、高低アクセントを勉強したことがなく、よく言うなら、大阪はこの言葉をこのように言います しかし、標準的な日本人はこのようなものなので、実際にはあなたの日本人が非常に断片化されたように聞こえるかもしれないような場所を飛び越えることができるので、異なる方言があるのでそれはそれであるという概念に同意しません 高低アクセントを完全に無視してもかまいませんが、すでに大阪に住んでいるような人や、非常に長い間そこに住んでいる人、または近い将来、留学などのためにそこに行く予定の人には、アドバイスがあります。 私が一般的に与えるのは、あなたがまだこれらの場所の1つに行っていない場合で、限られた時間しかそこにいないことを知っているなら、おそらくそれでもスタッドを使うのは良いことです y高低アクセントは、あなたが大阪のように長い間住んでいて、あなたが聞く日本人の圧倒的多数が高低アクセントであり、高低アクセントを勉強したことがないなら、おそらくそれは無駄になるだろうと言いました 標準的な日本語の高低アクセントを勉強する時間です。私はイギリスに10年間住んでいて、イギリス英語に囲まれていて、過去10年間はイギリス英語しか聞いていません。アメリカ英語のように勉強し始めれば、 高低アクセントは、特に将来もそこに留まる予定がある場合は、おそらく最も効果的な時間の使い方ではありませんが、限られた時間だけそこにいる予定で、おそらく その後、別の地域で日本語を勉強する価値があると思います。特に、日本語の高低アクセントをできるだけネイティブに聞こえたい場合は、ここに良い質問があります。 音を言わないのと同じことを言うのはそうではありません。それは、母音eまたはuが含まれている日本語の単語がたくさんあり、その母音が囲まれていることを知らない人のためのものです。 母音が完全にはっきりしていないと実際に言っていない特定の音なので、私がいつも与える例は、日本語で行きたいという言葉を言う場合、それは非常にゆっくりと非常に慎重に言う場合ですが、 通常の速度で言うと、真ん中で言うように言うのではなく、重要なことなので、ええと、あなたはええと言っているのですが、あなたはあなたのボーカルに従事していません あなたが今言っているように、これはあなたがこれをするときではないということとは異なりますが、あなたが音をまったく言っていないというわけではありません、そしてそれが意味するのはあなたがフレーズという言葉を取り、そしてあなたが 作り上げられたフレーズは両方とも離婚しますが、離婚しているにもかかわらず edあなたはまだそれらの単語が異なって正しく発音されているのを聞くことができるので、母音をまったく言っていないわけではありませんまだそれの痕跡が残っています 母音の場合と同じように口を入れてください。ボーカルコードを使用していないので、突然質問に答えられるといいのですが、突然、たくさんの新しいコメントのようになりました。 私はイギリス人が世界での関連性のために戦っているので、ええと、とても面白いですええと、私がそれをしているのを見てみましょう、そして私はあなたが怠惰に言っているようなものだとさえ気づいていませんでした 実際には、同じようなことが英語でも起こります。これは無意識のうちに英語で行います。たとえば、赤ちゃんのクマの単語を英語で言うと、その単語を綴る方法で、チャットで入力します。 そして、単語f または、これらを連続して入力するので、今すぐチャットでカブスとカップを入力しました。これらの単語は両方とも、sssと発音されているネイティブの英語話者と見なされる文字srightssで終わります。 私たちがカブスと言った場合、私たちは実際にはそれがazであるかのようにsを言っていると言っているのではありません。 私たちは声帯をbに従事させます。これは、次の音に擦り付けられる声帯を従事させる勢いのようなものです。したがって、これらの単語は両方ともsで終わるという事実にもかかわらず、これらの単語のsは カブスではsの発音がazのように発音され、カップではsのように発音されるので、日本語の方言のアクセントに関しては同じ基本的な考え方です。 声帯をかみ合わせない、またはかみ合わせる あなたのボーカルコードは周囲の音に依存しますが、その区別が非常に興味深いものであることに気づかなかったので、日本語にはそのようなumの単語が非常に多く、実際にはそれらを言うのが難しいので、あなたがそれらを言うのは非常に難しいです 発音についてはわからないので、例のように、これについては、日本語での発音と呼ばれる別の無料のビデオで詳しく説明します。 無料のレッスン全体を見ることができます。これは、20分または30分のレッスンのようなものです。これについて詳しく説明しますが、フルボイスで行きたいと言った場合、実際にはそのように言うのは難しくなります。 日本語の音はいつも同じように発音されるという教科書がたくさんあるので、とても残念です。日本語の発音はとても簡単で、人々は無意識のようにこれを頭に入れているからです。 レベル非常に多くの戦争があり、彼らは従おうとしているので、実際には多くの声があり、周囲の音に応じて完全に変化する日本語の音がたくさんあるのに、すべての音が常に同じ規則を言っているので、言うのが難しいことになります 別の本当に良い例のように、私がチャットでこれを入力したような音は、日本語で7つの異なる方法で発音できます。常に、前歯の後ろに舌を向けたnのように発音します。 間違って発音されることもありますが、ほとんどの場合はそうではありませんが、実際にはあなたが言っている単語によって異なりますが、7つの発音があるので、誰かが2、3のチャットをしました。 ページのアクセントの重要性についてはたくさんありますが、口の動きはどれほど重要かと聞きました。口の中の特定の筋肉が発達していないため、日本語の発音に苦労していると聞きました。 えーと、日本語の発音が最初だとは思いませんが、私の日本語の発音と高低アクセントは決して完璧ではないと言って、この主題についてはよく知っていますが、より良い発音で話す人はたくさんいます。 今の私よりも高低アクセントはかなり難しいと思います。おそらく誰もそれについて話さないので、このようなリソースのように読んだり、私のパトレオンコースのように受講したりしない限り、学ぶのは難しいです。 以下の説明では、日本語の発音に関しては、英語のような言語に比べて、舌をどこに置くか、あごの位置などは比較的簡単だと思います。 日本語の勉強を始めたときに前もって学ぶと、大きな違いが生まれます。 再び大きな違いを生む前もっての発声については、特定の単語が言いやすくなるので、高低アクセントは日本の発音よりもはるかに難しいと思いますが、圧倒的多数の人々は発音を勉強することで恩恵を受けると思います 少なくともその時間に少し時間を割いてください。しばらくの間、ビデオを楽しんでいましたか。レッスンとユーモアの両方に感謝します。ありがとうございました。 別のトピックで東京の時間の経過とともに変化する単語の強勢アクセント私は、動詞が共役しているときに高低アクセントがどのように変化するかを理解するために、ネイティブの話し方をコピーするのが簡単でした。 そのような高低アクセントの話者は、かなり自然に彼らに来ることができますが、特にストレスアクセントの話者にとっては、少なくとも楽しみの基礎について学びます 日本の高低アクセントを学ぶ前の約3年間、かなり集中的に日本語を勉強したので、日本語の勉強を始める前に、大きな違いが生まれます。 高低アクセントについて学ぶ私は、この間ずっと何百もの言葉を間違って言っていたので、すぐにショックを受けました。圧倒的多数の人々は、特に無意識のうちにアクセント学習者を強調し、誤って彼らが ほとんどの場合そうではないので、すべてを正しい方法で言うので、私の2セントだけですが、ノルウェー語のように、高低アクセント言語も信じているので、ノルウェー語を話す人の多くは、自然に自然に再現することで自然に再現するのがはるかに簡単です。 日本語の高低アクセントのパターンを明確に研究することなく、 自分の母国語にもよるけど、耳がどれだけいいかなど、松の木の間でキューティーパイの友情を教えてください。 実際に日本語の松の松の木とまったく同じように発音し、マツァを待つための動詞も同じですええと、それらは同じですここにあるのは本当に楽しい種類のクールな例です ええと、日本のネイティブスピーカーのような多くの人の心これは、日本のネイティブスピーカーに尋ねるのは楽しいことですええと、粒子は、状況によっては前の単語の高低アクセントパターンを実際に変更することはできません。 日本語での日本という言葉は、私が日本を愛していると言うなら、日本と言うことができますが、言葉の中にははっきりとした低高低がありますが、日本の人口のようなものを言うと、あなたはwr
ite nihon noその後、実際には異なるピッチアクセントパターンでjapanという単語を発音できます。これは、音符がピッチアクセントパターンを変更するため、同じピッチアクセントパターンでnihon noと言う人もいますが、多くのネイティブスピーカーはnihonno彼らと言うのではありません。 フラットパターンに変更すると、「にほん」とは言われません。どちらも受け入れられますが、音符によって前の単語の高低アクセントパターンが変わる可能性があることを知っておくと興味深いです。違いを見てみましょう。 とzumの間も良い質問ですこれは本当にクールな種類の楽しい事実ですこれも私のパトレオンシリーズでカバーしているものですが、私はペイチェックを詳細に分解します私は初心者の中級から上級者の高低アクセントだと思います レベルとかわいい私はそれをきちんとやっていると思うのが好きですが、それから私はまた、日本語のすべての音のすべての日本語の発音を分解するので、lのすべての音 ご存知のように、日本語のz音に関しては、多くの人が英語のz音と同じだと思っていますが、英語の例を見て、zがどのようになっているのかを見てみると楽しいです。 英語の音も変わる可能性があるので、ゼブラの単語を日本語または英語で言うと、ゼブラゼブラはその単語の最初のzが摩擦音と呼ばれ、それは私たちが一種の小さな通路のように作ることを意味します 口の中で息を吐き続けます。音はsrightzzのようなもので、at、a、a、ad、akのようなものとは異なります。これらの音はストップと呼ばれます。 あなたはそれらの音を言うと、実際に出て行く空気を遮断するので、すぐに言うことができますが、ゼブラのように英語で単語の先頭にazと言うと、ゼブラゼブラのように再び空気を吐き続けることができますええ、これは そういうこと meoneは、ピザと言うときのように言いましたが、ピザのzと言うとき、それは実際には苦痛です。つまり、実際に出て行く空気を1秒間停止します。ピザとは言いませんが、ピザと言います。 ええええピザのように聞こえるので、日本語では逆のことが当てはまります。英語では、単語の先頭にあるazは継続的なものであると私は信じていますが、ゼブラゼブラゼブラのようですが、状況によっては つまり、それはストップのようなものになります。それは、アフィリエイトピザピザですが、日本語では、日本の単語がzで始まり、前に音がない場合は、日本の単語の先頭で反対になります。 ピザだから、ドンネンのように不幸な言葉を言うと、日本人の人の言うことを注意深く聞くと、彼らは言うザンのようには言わないだろうと彼らは言うでしょうそして彼らは実際に彼らの舌に触れてその言葉を言い始めるでしょう p 高低アクセントの部分が口蓋の一部に触れているので
、zやゼブラのようなこの継続的なものではありませ
ん。
ピザの
舌の位置にあるzは少し異なります
が、多かれ少なかれ同じです。
zにも
2つの発音があり
、周囲の音によって変化し
ます。たとえば、
禅のように単語を言うと、英語で禅と言うと、禅と言います。
これは、この継続的な
ことのようですが、日本語で言うと、禅ではありませ
ん。
もう一度あなたと一緒にあなたはあなたの舌から始めます
そして
それは小さな違いですそしてそれはピッチアクセント
の違いのように大きな違いではありません
がそれ
を注意深く聞くとあなたはそれを聞くでしょう
そしてそれはとても面白いです
ええそうです それは
tsのようなものです
それはそれがそのようなものであるということを除い
てそれは最初ではなく
それは広告です
ええそれは
誰かがちょうどそれを書いたの
ですオイスターとパーセント柿のピッチアクセントはどうですか
私はいつも 私
はカキや生意気なものを食べたことがないので、
これらを調べ
なければなり
ませんええと、オイスターは生意気
ですが、柿は
生意気
です。  zが
単語の先頭に来て、
先行する
有声音がない場合はtrueですので、かなり複雑です
が、それは
日本の雑学の
ようなものですが、私のようなものに興味があるかどうかを知るのはクールです
だから
誰かが話していたと言った彼らは日本語で言っ
たコメントは私
は日本語の音が
ネイティブの英語を話す人にとって
は難しいと
よく耳にします
それは特に真実だと思いますが、
もう1つの興味深い違い
は、
一部の話者にとって難しい理由の1つは
、日本語のすべての音
の舌の位置が舌の位置と異なるためです。
英語のtの音で、
物事を詳細に分析するためにhey uh
podcast hey doganいつもの
ように、あなたが私たちのポッドキャストに来たことを本当に感謝しています。
または
、高低アクセントがほとんど流暢
ではないので
、2つの高低アクセントのどちらかを選択する必要がある
場合は、非常に良い質問です。
iiiが主張するように、言語を勉強するのはまったく無意味です
が、良いことは、あなたが
選択する必要がないということです。あなたが選択したものであれば、あなたは
良い日本語を持ち、また良い高低
アクセントを持つことができます。
勉強しましたが、寄付に感謝
します。
ポッドキャストに参加するのが大好きでした。とても楽しかった
です。日本語の
tの音は
、英語のtの音とはジェットとは異なる
ので、
ええと、テーブルを見てみましょう
英語のテーブル
t
テーブルあなたは
あなたの舌の先端があなたの
肺胞隆起の後ろに触れていることに気付くはずですとても
あなたの舌の先端が今
右の
テーブルテーブルに触れているあなたの上部前歯のすぐ後ろのその種の隆起のようなものです
日本の舌で
あなたは日本茶にいます
日本で日本舌
であなたの舌の先端は
実際にあなたの上部前歯の後ろに触れます
そしてそれで
彼らが言っているときに日本人の口を見ると
舌が少し見えることが多いようですが
、
こうじんたきを
個人的に言うと、個人的にはこうじんてきという言葉に
なります。舌を見ると、
舌の位置がわかります。
ええと
、英語のお茶と比較して、舌のように口の中で少し前に見えることがよくあります。そのため、英語のお茶
は少し後ろにあり、
日本のお茶は少しだけ後ろにあります。
orwardそしてまた
誰かが今言及したもう一つの本当に大きなポイントは
願望です
日本人は
ええと英語よりも願望が少ない
ので私
が言葉に応じてうまく言うなら基本的にあなた
がktpktpで始まりchのような日本語で言葉を言うとき
あなたは 息を吐き出さないように
田中田中という名前を言ったり
、アライグマのような良い例を言ったり
するといいでしょう
日本語でたぬきという言葉を言ったら大丈夫です
アライグマ
が狂い始めたとき
に回ったミームが日本人の女性のようで、彼女は
ええ、これはペンのことで、彼女
はこれがペンのようだった
ので、
これは実際には少し真実です
コビッドが最初に日本で夢中にならなかった理由としてこれを引用するのはばかげていると思います
が、
日本語は
英語よりもumの願望が少ないので
、日本語でum killと言った場合、または 私は英語でキルと言います
この時計を見てくださいキルキルキルで組織がどれだけ動くか
今私はそれを
超誇張された方法で言うのでは
ありません 私はそのkの前にsを置きますそれは
実際にkの発音を変える
ので英語でakの前にsiが付い
ている場合私はこれを正しく理解していると信じてい
ます
殺すのに比べて組織はまったく動かないので、
私は背中合わせに
スキルスキルスキルスキルスキルスキル
スキルを言っているので、それは本当に大声で言ってい
ますが、それは実際には正しく動いていません
スキルスキルスキル スキルスキルですが、
キルに切り替えるとすぐにキルになります。
キル
で
は多くの願望があり、私たち
はたくさん息
を吐きます。そうです
、最初のkでたくさん息を吐きますが、日本の
kは それらの2つの中間のような
ものと私が意味するもの つまり、単語の最初に来るときの英語のkと比較して、単語
の最初に来るときの日本語のkでは、ほとんど息を吐き出さない
ので
、少し動くようになります。 しかし、
kill right
kill
ほどでは
ないので
、それは非常に正しく動くので、ktpは日本語で聞こえますが、それら
は
よく動くよりもはるかに少ない
です。
あなたがネイティブの
英語を話す人なら、ネイティブの英語を話す人
なら、ネイティブのアメリカ人の
英語を話す人
なら、
無意識のうちにこの殺すスキルを再現できるはずです。ティッシュを手に入れて
、もう一度言ってみてください。
キル
対
スキルスキルスキルスキルスキルそれはまったく動いていません
それから私が
再び
殺すために切り替えるとすぐにそれはたくさん動くので
ええこれはペンな
ので
、彼らがコレと言うならそれは実際にネイティブの日本人スピーカーです
起こった彼らはexh ネイティブスピーカーがこれがペンだ
と言った場合、ネイティブスピーカーが言った場合よりもはるかに少ないですが、それ
が実際に
ええと
、日本で
どれほどクレイジーなコロナが早くから起こったかのように、誰が実際に貢献しているかを知っています
が、私は
そのミームが動き始めたときはとても面白いと思ったのは、
彼らが話していることを誰も本当に知らなかったから
です。彼らは明らかに同じであるようにとてもばかげています
が、実際には
そう
ではないので、かなり面白いです
が、ペンは同じように発音されます 両方の
言語で、実際には
日本語の
ペンではそうではありません。
ペンの最初のpで
、英語と比べ
て日本語でほとんど吐き出さないので、良いミームになります。
数分間、
言語で遊んでいるティッシュに、興味があるかもしれない人のために、
ここに戻ってきた血の流れについてコメントした人が
います。ええと、私はエルデンリングを手に
入れました。  co 完全な傑作
ソフトウェアからどれほど優れている
か信じられません。彼らが作った信じられないほどの素晴らしいゲームです。
私は
あなたのビデオを本当に楽しんでいます。
アドバイスに感謝します。
その後、日本語の講師と一緒にレビューして、
3〜6か月でお会いしましょう。
すべてのコンテンツが
素晴らしいです。もっと初心者レベルのコンテンツを作成してください。
アドバイスをありがとうございます。
最近見てきたかどうかはわかり
ません。 レッスン5から10ですが、
最近レッスン6.3を作り直し
ました。これは、ピッチアクセントとイントネーションの違いについて話しているので、この時点でシリーズの中で最も重要なレッスンになると思います。
最高のゲームは文字通り
最初のレベルを打ち負かすのに何日もかかりましたそれから私は速くなりました
あなたは日本語でエルドンリングをプレイしていますかええとはいはい私は日本語でエルドンリングをプレイしています
比較的近い将来にツイッチでストリームを再生する可能性がありますが、今夜でも
エルドンリングのボスを殺しただけです。
これはバックグラウンドで面白いです
が
、少なくとも近い将来、おそらくYouTubeでそれを行うことはないでしょう
が、それは このような
素晴らしいゲーム
については、過去にも少し話しました
が、
ファイナルファンタジー
VIIとジェットグラインドラジオは
、私の人生を根本的に変えた2つ
のゲームでした。
それ以外にプレイしたのは楽しい時間のようなものでしたが
、
ファイナルファンタジーVIIや
ジェットグラインドラジオをプレイしたときは
、まるで
芸術作品のように本当に重要なもののように取り組んでいるように
感じました。 少し前の適切なパーソナリティテスト分析のように、
これらすべての特性が本当に低いようでしたが、芸術
と創造性を扱うこの特性が本当に高い
ので、興味深いものでした。 あなたの性格のおかげで、
あなたはおそらく
音楽映画の
本や他の種類の芸術に本当に本当に情熱を注ぐ
ような人です、そして私はそうだったの
です
私はこのライブストリームのように100,800人の視聴者がいるので、矛盾した言い方をします
が、ええと、
私は一人でいるのが好きです。私は外向的であるよりも内向的
です。
物事を説明しますが、アートは
私にとって非常に重要です。
そういうわけで、私がapuでフルタイムで働いていたとき、
私は作るのが好き
かどうかわからないのに、YouTubeを
やるつもりだったのです。 近い将来かどうかは
わかりませんが、私はこれを行う必要
があり
ます。愚かなコメディービデオを知っているような
ものであれ、それが
私にとって重要であるものであれ、ある種の芸術で自分自身を表現する方法を持たなければなりません。
だから私が非常に深い元を持っていたとき ファイナルファンタジーVIIをプレイして
いたときの経験、
そして最初のジェットグラインドラジオ
も、まるでアウトロバートと言ったかのようでし
た。適切なものを
思い出せません。ええと、
ええと、何を言っているのですか。
英語のアウトロバート
それはとんでもない外向的ではありませんあなたはそこに
行きます外向的な
歌
[笑い]
それを釘付けにしました
とにかく
ファイナルファンタジー7とジェットグラインドラジオ
それらのゲームは
私の人生を根本的に変えましたそれは
私が遊んでいたときに感じた感情のようでした
それらのゲーム
、特に
それらのゲームの音楽が好きで、アートスタイル
やキャラクター、そしてストーリーが好きでした。
これは驚くべき
ことでした。
私がビデオゲームをプレイしてきた何年もジェット
グラインドラジオジェットセットラジオ
あなたが日本語で遊んでいるか英語で遊んでいるかにかかわらず、ラジオは違う名前です
が
、私の
いとこ
は本当にこれを強くお勧めします
私にとってのゲームは
彼がプレイしていたのですが、彼はそれ
をプレイしなければなら
なかったのです。
または
、彼が余分なコピーを持っていたのか、それとも
彼がすでにコピーを終えたために私にコピーを送ったのかを思い出せませ
ん。2015年のように
軽くたたくわけではありません。
でも、
ええと、Bloodborneをチェックして
、同じような経験をしました。
これは、このゲームをプレイ
することで人生が大幅に改善されたように
感じられるので、とても良いです。
iiはそれを言い、iiは、私が
それを言うとき、私が
実際にそれを意味していなかっ
たとしても、他のゲームについては言わない
だろうということを意味します。 同様に
私はエルドンリングだと思います私はちょうど始めたばかりのようです
が私は
血まみれの
ええと誰かが言ったよりもいい
と
思う アウトロバートマーチ勝つええええ私
たちはアウトロバートマーチをやるべきだと思いますoutronomaidens
ええ、それ
はソフトウェアからのええと私は宮崎の歌
だと思います
今すぐ複製
するまだ
秋の
オートマトンの近くのシリーズも
そうだと聞いたことがあります。多くの人
がウィッチャー3についても言及している
ことを経験しました。
ビデオゲームをプレイするので
、私は選択する必要があります。私のいとこ
は
、私が好きなゲームと嫌いなゲームを十分に知っている
ので
、ウィッチャー3もプレイしたようでした。 そして彼は
ええ魔女のようでした r 3あなたは
それが信じられないほど良いことを知っていますが、おそらくあなたは
Bloodborneがもっと共鳴することを知っているでしょう
それをチェックしてください
そして私はそうしましたそして私はああ私の神のようでした
比較的近い将来
、適切に接続できれば、今夜遅くに高低アクセントでいくつかのエルデンリングストリームを実行
しますが、ええと
[音楽
]いくつかのスーパーチャットがあり
ます。
ローンチ時
のサイバーファンクええと、それが何であるかは
わかりませんが、残念ながらps5もありません。
そのため、ps4でエルドンリングを演奏して
いますが、それでも、それは素晴らしいことだと思います。
人々の多くは、ピッチを発音
しようとしている深い声を持つ人々のためのファイナルファンタジーviのヒントについて話します
ええ、これは本当に良い
点でもあります実際に
は現象があると思いますそして
私は実際にこれについて詳細に話しました
私のピッチ
アクセントプロによく 以下の説明にリンクされている告知シリーズ
ですが、
特に西海岸のアメリカ英語で
は、きしみ声または声帯フライと呼ばれる
ものがあり
ます。それは、あなたが言葉を言って
いるときにあなたが 「吐き出す
速度は
、言葉全体で吐き出す速度
がどんどん
遅くなります。
その結果、私がああの
ように絶えず吐き出している
場合、何が起こっているのかというと
、 私の声帯を通過する空気と
それらは振動していますが、声帯自体が正しく接触しないように絶えず
通過するのに十分な空気があるようにそれらは触れ
て
いません
が
、あなたが吐き出す空気の量を十分に遅くすると
それからあなたの声帯が
実際に触れ始め
、それはこのきしみ声の
声帯の稚魚の音のようになり、これを複製
するのはああのように聞こえます
それはその種の谷の谷のようなものです
このような女の子のこと
と
これは
音韻論でこれです
言語学の用語は再びええときしみ声きしみ声ときしみ声は
日本語よりも英語ではるかに一般的であり
、これの理由の1つは日本
人とこれが 一般論
ですが、一般的に
は、
日本語を話しているときのネイティブの日本人スピーカーは、英語よりも
一定の
頻度で、より一定のペースで空気を吐き出す傾向があると思います。
私の経験では、ネイティブの英語スピーカー
は吐き出す傾向があります。 最初はかなりの量
で、ステートメントの最後ではすぐに落ち
ます。そのため、言葉の終わりのように、
きしみ声は専門用語のようには聞こえません
が
、英語ではきしみ声とボーカルフライです。 私たちは言葉の終わりで遅くなる傾向があり
ます特に
西海岸の英語のように谷の女の子英語
ああボーカルフライ
ええ
と
それは日本語にはあまり存在しません
そして探求 誰かが尋ねたイオン
は、あなたが深い声を持っている場合はどうしますか？それはあなたが
より深い声を出す方法の1つが
あなたの声帯を通過する空気の量を遅くすることであるというのが私の理解であるかどうかです
いつ
でも、あなたが試みた場合、
あなたが吐き出している空気の量と少しだけ一貫性を
保つ
ようにしようとする
と、少しだけ意識して、もう一度もっと多くのことをしようとすることを意識し
てください。 高低アクセント
との一貫性のようなものに役立つはずの日本語の話し方でもう少し息をのむ
これはあなたにとって興味深い逸話かもしれ
ません申し訳ありませんが今私の部屋の温度をチェックします
ここで少し暑く
なるので、ええと
、ええと
、私が最初にYouTubeビデオを作り始めたとき
、構造
が非常に単純であるという点で誰もが私のYouTubeビデオを知っているので、それ
は数冊の本の前にいる私だけです。 背景が白く
て、それが正しく変わることはない
ので、もちろん
スクリプトをできるだけ良くしたかったのですが、キャラクターがたくさんいると本当に好きだったら
、私のビデオ
はもう少し魅力的だと思いました
私の声で、そして私が最初にやろうとしたこと
は
、私の日本のコメディービデオで私の声のピッチを
非常に早い段階
で人為的に下げようとしたことです。
私のYouTubeチャンネルで私の初期のビデオのいくつかを見ると、これを見ること
が
できます。
何が起こったのかと
いうと、声の高さを下げたために、高低アクセント
のパターンで問題が発生し始め
ました。低音で話していて、
あまり空気を吐き出していない場合は
、 私の経験で
は、日本語に常に存在するさまざまな高低アクセントパターンが正確にヒットしました。
これも、日本語の
ネイティブスピーカーは
、英語とは対照的に、かなり規則的なペースで息を吐き出す傾向があるためです。  hどこにでもある
ので
、日本語の発音と高低アクセントで話しているようなものでしたが、英語を母国語とする人と
同じくらいの量の空気を吐き出し、吐き出すだけ
で、私の日本語は
本当に奇妙な響きになりました。
少し後でそれ
を理解しました。多かれ少なかれ修正できたと思いますが、もう一度試してみると、
吐き出す空気の量をもう一度意識するようになります。
日本語を話せば、ステートメント
の最後まで息を吐き続けることを考え
てみてください。
そうしようとすると、日本語が話されたときに少しずつ優れているとドーガンが言った
ように、大丈夫です。
キング
オーケー
[音楽]
なぜ高低アクセントのような単語
がオンライン辞書に複数の高低アクセントを持って
いるのかええと、多くの
単語が異なる高低アクセントパターンを持っている理由はたくさんあります
1つは
申し訳ありません
が、この単語には当てはまらない
理由の1つですが、その理由の1つは
、昔
、標準的な
日本語と特定の日本の方言の間で
、一部の単語と非常に多くの重複があった単語があることです。 単語は複数の
発音を持っているだけ
です日本語には複数の発音を持っている単語
がいくつかありますが、多くはありませんが
、複数の発音を
持っている単語
もあります。
標準的な日本のピッチアクセントと
デボイシングルールに関して何か奇妙なことが起こっ
て
いるために複数の発音が発生する多くの単語とは、これが良い例
です。日本語の新聞レポートレポーターのようなレポーターの単語は
kishaです。  kisha
um
と
私はおそらくほとんどの人がkishakishaの
ようにそれを言うと思い
ますが、その音のeは無声になる可能性があるためです それから私は
これを私のシリーズでも詳細に分解します
が、ダウンステップが発生するはずの場所で発声が発生した
場合、それ自体が一種の矛盾であることが
よくあります。
声帯を実際に使用して
いないため、ピッチは不可能です。声帯を
再び使用していない
ため、音はピッチを伝えることができないため
、それを補う
ために使用します。
ええと、
代わりに彼ら
が
言ういくつかのネイティブスピーカー
とにかく、同時に互いに矛盾するような
複数の
高低アクセント規則がある
場合、その単語はしばしば複数の
正しい発音を持ちます。これが良い
例です。 これがもう1つの良い
例です。
一般的
に、圧倒的多数の
場合
、日本語のすべての動詞
は、単語の最後から2番目のモーラで発生し
ます。 いくつかのリストを実際にすばやくプルアップする
ので、動詞にダウンステップがある場合、
圧倒的な大多数の場合、圧倒的にそう、
そのダウンステップが発生します。
単語の最後から2番目のモーラです。これは、動詞にダウンステップがある
場合の日本語の標準的なルールのようなものです。
ダウンステップ
は、単語の最後から2番目のモーラで発生し
ます。はい、これは高低アクセント
辞書です。 さて
、日本語には別の規則があります。つまり
、末尾の
母音が2つ並んでいる場合
、その母音ペアの2番目の母音は下降ステップを
とることができない
ので、
誰かがkaieru
とre カではなくカエルと言うの
は、カイルが例外であるためです。これは
、
1つの母音
が2番目の母音である
ためです。正確に言えば、これは
矛盾の例です。
日本の高低アクセントの別の規則は、
後続の母音
ができるということです。  tにはダウンステップが含まれている
ため、
技術的にはダウンステップは1つの
ルールに従ってカイエルである必要があります
が、これ
は
末尾の母音であるため、ダウンステップは
1モーラ戻り、日本語の少数の動詞のようになります。
末尾の母音が
あるアクセントは単語の最後から2番目の音節ではありませんが、
これらの単語のいくつかは
実際には
複数の正しい発音
を持っています。 方法と一部のスピーカー
は、私が私の研究で出くわしたことがないことを知らない別の方法でそれを言うでしょ
うええと、カンのええと、
ええ、これはピッチアクセントをうまく運びません
これは例外の例だと言う人もいますが、これは例外の例です。
今すぐ辞書に表示すると、2つの
正しい高低アクセントが表示されます
が、これもほぼ確実に2つの高低アクセントがあるためです。
互いに矛盾
しているルールなので、受け入れ可能な発音が複数あるため、
これは難しい
です。これらすべてをどのように覚えているので、
これは難しいです。
非常に多くのルールがありますが、
問題は
私です。 日本語の
高低アクセントシリーズ
では、覚えておかなければなら
ないルール
を覚えておくのが良いと思い
ます。時間とエネルギーがあれば覚えておくべき
ルール、そして覚えて
おくべきルール あなたが本当に本当にこのようなものに興味があるかどうかを覚えておいてください
、しかし
ここに本当に良い例があります、そして
これは私が過去に私が話したもう一つの例です
圧倒的
多数の
ビート4モーラ2
カンジは日本語で名詞だった
ので、
またはum
et cetera et ceteraは
すべて同じ高低アクセントパターンに従います。
これは
、通常のスピーチでは多かれ少なかれフラット
です。
すぐにあなたの話す
日本語
を目立つ程度に改善しますそれは1つの単純なルールのようなものです
4つのモーラ2つの
高低アクセントパターン
その月以降、日本語を聞くと、
二度と間違った言葉を言うことはありません。
また
、文字通り
何百もの日本語の単語の正しい発音を一晩で知ることができます
。
高低アクセントを言うのをやめます。
例外ですが、
高低アクセントのルールを知っておく必要があるので、高低アクセントのルールを知っておく必要があります。
私のシリーズでは、
これらのルールも知っておく
とよいと思います。頭に入れるだけで、
必ずしも覚えておく必要はありませんが、
今でも気付いた場合は、
後でそのルールが正確に何であるかを忘れてしまった場合、それ
はまったく学習しないよりもまだ
良いので、ピッチアクセントにどのオンライン辞書を使用しますか
私はさまざまなものを
使用し
ます この鈴木
と別のスズキはfourvo.comです誰かがええ
と言った
ええと、去年からあなたはどれくらいの頻度で
あなたのコースを更新しましたか
？
特定の非常に重要なレッスンのリメイクをアップしたので、そのうちの1つ
はレッスン6.3のようなもの
で、ピッチの微妙な低下など、
イントネーションとピッチアクセントの違いについて話
し
ます。これは、これでカバーするもう1つの興味深いことです。 ストリームです
が、
私はそれを組み合わせてやっていますが、
必ずしも基礎的なリメイクを必要と
しないレッスンでは、発音をしているレッスンで
は、高品質のネイティブ録音でそれらすべてを更新しています
nhkの
発音のようなアカデミーに通ったネイティブスピーカー、または
そうそう話す学校のように
、ネイティブの
録音は確かに私の録音よりも優れていると思う
ので、それは
私がやってきたもう一つのことです
更新
基本的
には私のシリーズに関連する少なくとも1つのことです少なくとも
151617日ごとに約
過去1年間
、私は
ゼロからのリメイクのようにした
ことがあり、それよりも時間がかかりましたが、私は試しました
一貫性
を保つために、これからも続けていき
ます。高低アクセントの日本語について説明している本をお勧めしますか。
アクセント辞書
は良いです。
テーブルが読みやすいように
、日本語で使用するのはとても簡単ですが、これ
ほど詳細ではないと
思います。シムマカイニホンは
この休憩を歩きます。 高度な
ルールをもう少し詳しく説明します
が、日本語の高低アクセントの基本的な紹介のようにしようとしているのであれば
、この本の
アクセントはそうだと思います。 今はその単語の高低アクセントがわからなかったので、
2、3分
前
に話したルールのせいで爆弾だと思ったのですが、ルールが健全だとわかっていたので正しかったです。
健康的で
、
これは日本語で非学術的な読みやすい方法で物事を分解するのに本当に良い仕事をし
ます。
もしあなたが日本語を扱えるなら、あなたが
推薦するそれらの本のリストを見ることができる場所があります。
リンクか
何かええと l
here uh oops whoa oh no
OK私はまだライブストリーミングをしていると思いますええと
1秒私は誤っ
てウィンドウを閉じたので、それ
を元に戻さなければなりません
私たちは戻ってきた
ので、私がお勧め
するリソースだけをリストする場所はあり
ませんが、
私のウェブサイトに公開されている参考文献ページがあります。もちろん、すべての高低アクセントリソースを見ることができます。
大学で高低アクセントコースを受講し
て、
過去20年くらい、15
年くらい、10年くらいくらい、こういうことを意識しようとして得た知識に加えて、
こう言いたいみたいなものがあります。
そのページには少なくとも50のリソースがあるので
、わかり
にくいです。toshokangum
の正しい発音方法を教えてください
[音楽]
ああ、toshokanだと思います。
ええと
、この単語であなたをつまずかせるようなものはありますか。
ピッチアクシデントは音楽にどのように適用されます
か cしたがって、一般的なルールiiは
、
ピッチ
アクセントルールが
音楽に表示される場合があると考えていますが、
一般的に言えば、
音楽はピッチアクセントをオーバーライドする
ため
、多くの例があります。
曲のどこにあるのかをすばやく簡単に見つけることができます。
この歌手は
間違った高低アクセントパターンで単語を歌ってい
ます。そうですね、あなたは素晴らしい教育者でありコメディアンです。
あなたとあなたの家族が滞在していることを願っています。
これらの時間の間に安全で幸せ
ですありがとうええそれは世界で今起こっていることはクレイジー
です私は
ここで一種の接線ですが実際には
私はかなりの量のウクライナの血を持っています
私は4分の1のウクライナ人です 血の
ええと私のおばあちゃんは
明らか
にその崩壊のために
彼女は100パーセント彼女が
亡くなったのですが彼女はアメリカで生まれ育った血で100ウクライナ人ですしかしえ
えと私は彼女の両親があなただったと信じています
ウクライナの移民な
ので
、別の世界で何
が起こっている
のかを見るのは奇妙です。物事が少し違った形で行われたかどうかを知っていれば、今はウクライナにいることができたはずです。
私は
ウクライナにいくらかのお金を寄付しようとしました、そして私は
いくつかのリンクも共有しようとしました、しかし
ええ、私はウクライナへの神の神のスピードを意味しますそして私は
本当にその国の人々のために願って祈っ
ています私は
何が起こっているのか信じられません あそこ
[音楽]
さて、tから
dへの移行のためにマーゲートのようなフレーズを言うのは難しいと
思い
ます
これは
間違った
舌の配置が
原因であるか、これが原因で別の理由があります
それは再び舌の配置である可能性があります
日本語で
は、日本茶の舌は
前歯上部の後ろと
舌の刃に触れる必要があるので、
ここでは先端ではなく、
すぐ後ろのようなものを知っています
あなたの肺
胞隆起に反するはずのヒントですが、
magatixわからないの
ですが、そこで何が起こっているのかを正確に言うのは難しい
です。
マガル
ええ
、アクセントがないわけではないので
、短いフレーズに2つのアクセントがあります。
そういう意味で、マガッテとあなたが言うと、少し言いづらくなることが
あります。
正しいピッチアクセントパターンで
言うので、フラットと言ってもアクセントはありません。これは
、多くのネイティブの英語話者の
ように、タベルという言葉を聞いたり、タベタを聞いたりするのと同じことです。
日本語の「ストップ」という言葉は、日本人がトメロトメタと言っているのを聞いていると思っていても、
私たちが思っているのと同じように発音さ
れ
ます。
次の単語
の発音にも影響を与える可能性のあるピッチアクセントパターンを
台無しにしている場合は、アクセントが多すぎる
ため、
ここでも同じです。私は両親の両方が100ウクライナ人です。
彼らは難民だっ
たので、92年に私たちのところにやって来ました。
私が見たことがない国の故郷にとても近いです
。それはクレイジーだと思います。
もちろん、何が起こっているの
かは ロシアの人々です
が、もちろんロシアの
独裁者ですので、
もちろん私は非常に重要だと思います。
もちろん、
たとえば私
がウクライナ人である
という基金は、私がお金を寄付した支援基金とは何と言いますか。
私がフォローしている日本に住むロシアのイラストレーターが
、もちろん彼は
自分の役割を果たして
何が起こっているのかを残そうとしているので
、決してロシアのpeopのせいではないと思う
ロシアの
イディアの歌
えーと、日本の国境の状況についてどう思いますか。
少し前に移民規制
というビデオを作りました。コメディーのレンズを通してそれについて考えてみた
ので
、もしあなたがそれをチェックすることをお勧めします。 見たことが
ないええと
、
見てみましょう大丈夫、続けましょ
うええと、トラッシュテイストの男の子とポッドキャストでコラボレーションする計画はありますか？
ええ、ジョーイがずっと前に私を招待してくれた
ので、これはとても面白いです それが続く切望されたもの
で
、私は少しの間コベットについて不平を言うつもり
です、しかし
私が予約
をしたようにそして私が行く準備ができているように私が
実際
にジョーイに手を差し伸べたような時が3回ありました
えーと、この時間に空いて
いたら、東京に行く予定
がありました。もしあなたが空いているかどうか、また知っていれば、会いましょう
。
彼はそうだったので、
会いましょう。 そして、
ええと
、それはデの直前だったので、私はキャンセルしなければなりませんでした
lta波が起こって
、文字通り
私が行く予定だった
週末は、ゴミの味からのガーネット
がkovidで落ちた週末だったので、大丈夫
にならないのはおそらく正しい決断だったようですが、
うまくいけば
、このデルタの後で物事が落ち着くでしょう 波
それは
今の州で物事が好きになるようですそして
それが最初に本当に激しくスパイクした日本の基地のようないくつかでは
物事が下がっているように見えますああちょっと
フォックスハウンドどうですかちょっとやめてくれて
ありがとう ええと
、でもええ、今回はもう少し落ち着い
たら、忙しい時間もあれば行けるといいのですが、
事前に連絡を取り、十分な通知をしたいと思います。
みんながかっこいいことを確認してください
そうそうオミクロン申し訳ありませんデルタでは
ありません申し訳ありません申し訳ありません私は混乱しました
ええオミクロンはデルタで
はないと思っ
ていました
書く私はあまり話してい
ないので、ビデオのアイデアや発音や単語の選択などの多くの
こと
ああ、夏は
どう
ですか？あなたの商品がどれほど素晴らしいかを言うのを忘れまし
た。 それを上げて、
それはバグアウトのようなものです
ので、
今チャットで様先生を知らない人のために、
彼女は日本人を除いて私がすることと非常に似ている
こと
をしているので、私
は学習している人々に日本の高低アクセントと発音を教えます
夏は正反対の
日本語を教えます彼女は英語
を深く
発音します私は高低アクセントを言いたいです
が、英語はストレス
アクセント言語
です言語音韻論の音声学に関しては高レベルの知識を使用
して英語の発音を明確かつ簡潔に分解します
非常にプロフェッショナルな方法
で私を紹介してくれ
てありがとう 今のところ
、近い将来、
私は夏を台無しにするのが好きではなかったと思います
が、夏はとてもクールで、
彼女は英語
を学ぼうとしている日本人のための素晴らしいチャンネルを持っている
ので、
私たちの かなり近い将来のコラボレーションは
とにかく外国人
をチェックする大丈夫とにかく私はみんなに夏をチェックすることを強くお勧めします
彼女は素晴らしいチャンネルを持っていますそして
彼女の日本人ももちろん驚異的
です honshu umいい
質問なので
、東京のuh ko大学に1年間留学しました。東京
は、私のような人にとっては1年ほどのように過ごすのに最適な場所だと思います。東京
は素晴らしい場所であり、
励まします。 誰もがそれをチェックする
が、内向性のため
に私が以前に言った外向性とは対照的
に、内向性のために私はあなたが知って
いる大分のような穏やかな場所でええとのような場所ではるかにうまく
いく 大阪に住んでいる人が少ないゆ
しゅう東京に住んでいる私は日本の主要
都市の
ほとんどに行ったことがありますが、人口の多い高低アクセントでは、ここで最もくつろげます。
約13万人の
方がご存知のようにとても落ち着いて
いて忙しくない
です東京にいたときに疲れただけで
燃え尽きてしまったので
最初
は吹き飛ばされたような感じでした 後に
なってようやく二重むち打ちのようになったように思い
ました
[音楽]
えーと、日本語のアクセントをマスターし
ていたの
は、正式な教育の一環として自然に生まれた
ものか、検索しなければならなかったものです。
自分で考えてみてください。
これは本当に良い質問です。これは
、日本語でコミュニケーションをとるために日本語の方言のアクセントを勉強する必要がないという、ある種の修正に自分の役割を果たそうとしていることです。
高低アクセントを勉強したことがない場合
圧倒的多数の
場合、ネイティブスピーカーが
あなたの言っていることを正確に理解する
のに少し時間がかかり
、あなたと彼らの間にもう少し距離があるとしても、高低アクセントを勉強したことが
なければ、あなたはまだあなたのポイントを理解することができます
そうは言っ
ても、そのため、そして
この時点まで、
非大学院生やこれまでに
経験したことのない人々のように、物事を非常に簡単に説明するリソースのように、高低アクセントを分解する簡単な方法は実際にはありませんでした。 勉強した
言語学は簡単に理解できます。
日本の教科書出版社の多くは、この教科書
のスペースが限られているのと同じように大丈夫だと
思い
ます。おそらく、
これらを使用している人々に許可することに集中する必要があります。
勉強している言語で人々とコミュニケーションをとるための本な
ので、
高低アクセントがこのようなケーキの上にあるアイシングのようなものであれば
、それは必要ありません
が 大きな違いを生むことができ
ますそれを含めないようにしましょうそして
それ
は過去30年から40年の間の一種の
前例でした
高低アクセントについて少し知っているだけで、聞き
方が根本的に変わり、
日本語が話せるので、これは残念だと思います。
コメディービデオとコースの両方で私がやろうとしていること
は私です。 興味の
ある人に高低アクセントを
教えるだけでなく、400人の
同時視聴者の
ようにドロップダウンするのが
好き
です。 これは
、最新のum
ビデオの内容であり、日本語のフラトのように、状況によっては日本語について
一般化できるものがあることを知っています。
一部の人々を助けますが
、できるだけネイティブに聞こえることに興味がある人々にとっては
、少なくとも
高低アクセントと呼ばれる
ものがあり、それを研究しようとしている場合
は利用可能なリソースがあるという言葉を広める方がはるかに良いです 私の
友達の
マット対日本と彼の他の
友達のケンも最近、
高低アクセントを教える独自のコースを開始したので、できるだけ自然に聞こえる
ことに興味がある人にとってはもっと楽しいと思います
私の意見では、高低アクセントを勉強
することは非常に重要なことです。
これは、
夏が実際にメールで私に話していた良いこと
です。これは、
私が私の1つで話したことです。 ビデオそれはずっと前の
ことですが
、母音のようになると
、いわば同じような現象のように英語で同じようなことが起こり、
言語学の知識が少しでもできるようになります 長い
道のり
で、多くの言語で英語の母音弱化と呼ばれるものがありますが、
英語でも同様
です。つまり、アクセント
を受け取る英語の単語の母音を言うと、
その単語のアクセントのある音節が
その母音を完全に明瞭に表現しますが
、周囲の母音の多くの結果として
、英語で象の単語を言う場合、
それはe
la
fent
ではない
ので、象の象を完全に明瞭に表現します。
次に
、eが受け取るので、
それは単語のアクセントであるため、
音節で母音の象を完全に明瞭に表現できます
が、その単語の他の2つの母音
は、
私たちが「ええと、それはスワッシュです」と言うだけです。
バナナ
バナナははるかに良い例
です。それらはすべて同じ母音です。それはすべて
正しいですが、私たちが言うバナナとは言いません
[音楽]
そして唯一の理由は
、真ん中の母音が完全
に正しい方法で明瞭に表現されているからです。 それ
が再び母音を受け取る母音
がストレスを受ける音節であり、
ストレス
のない音節の母音が
減少するのは、
私たちがよく言う
母音の母音と同じ理由です
。 これについては過去に少し話しまし
たが
、英語では「マッチャ
」と言いますが、日本語
では
、その単語の両方の母音を適切に表現している
と言っても、英語で言うと、2番目の母音は言いません。
ああ
、それは日本語で言うように言うのではなく、
悪い発音で言うと母音が
減るということです。英語を母国語
とする人で、そうだとしたら
、それは良いことです。
例ええええ正確にええ私は
それがあなたがネイティブの英語を話す人ならそれはええとそれ
はあなたが別の良い例のように無意識に日本語を話しているときにおそらくかなりの量の母音弱化をしていることを知っているのは本当に良いことです
e
は、uh runの単語
が日本語
である場合、最初にhaを完全に表現するのではなく、ネイティブの英語を話す人が多い場合
です。これ
は、haのアクセント
が次のように言う傾向があるためですが、
hoshiduではありません。
したがって、一般的に言えば
、d voicingの現象を除いて、日本の
母音をより明確に表現することをお勧めします。これについて
も、このストリームと
以前のビデオで
詳しく説明しました
。英語を母国語とする場合は、
おそらくあなたの母音を減らしています。 ある程度の日本の母音
ですが、それは
あまり良いことで
はありません。言語の知識
が単語の選択に影響を与えると思いますか。英語の
極端な場合、
シェイクスピアのように詩に現れるように見えるとしたら、どのように見えるでしょうか。
em
bic
penometer and whatnot OK私は
その単語を正しい方法で言っているかどうかわかりません
が、単語の選択
に関しては
、mよりも創造的な感度に頼ろうとしています y
言語の感度そしてそれ
はいくつかの言葉
があるから
です 音
は一般的に
他の音よりも
面白くなりがちなので、私は元気
ですが、2、3
語のよう
に同じことを言うことができる例は確かにたくさんあります。
最も賢く聞こえる言葉のように選ぶのではなく
、私は最も単純な言葉や最も面白いと思う言葉を使う傾向があります。
私がこれまで読んだ本やそのようなもの
は、言語学を教えるときに大いに役立ちますが、
言語学
を教えるときはもちろん、あなたが話すときもそうです
が、私は コメディックビデオのように書くm
物事の言語的側面を
あまり浸透させないようにします。おそらく
、ビデオを作成するたびに
、同じ行を5〜15回録音する傾向がある
ので、次のようになります。 どもこにちわと言うと、
そういう単純な線
とは違うかもしれませ
んが、
何度も何度も言う傾向があり、
いつも選んでしまう
線は、私が思う線です。
私が最高の日本語の発音を持っていると思う線よりもおかしい
ので
、それは私の創造的な感性を作成する例です
泡泡それはちょうど
それは面白いかわいい響きの
言葉の
ようなものです
いくつかの音のように、
多くの人が無意識のうちに
面白いと感じる言葉
があります。良い例のように、
今日は少し暑いように言うことができ
ます。
まるで標準的
な感じのようなもの
ですが、日本語で言うと、
暖かくて晴れ
ているように、少し違う
感じになりますが、ニュアンスは何と言いますか？
同時に
、ニュアンスだけでなく、
言葉の一般的な感じはまったく
異なります
。2番目の言葉は
もっとフレンドリーで
遊び心のある感じな
ので、それは別の良い例です。
私は
すぐに学校から双子の娘を迎えに行くようになったので
、誰か
が
迎えに
来て、ネイティブjと話しているあなたのビデオを作りたい場合は、さらに5分間ストリーミングします。
apaneseスピーカー
私たちはまだ待ってい
ますあなたがグーグルヨーコとドルガムならええ
と、そのビデオは完全に
日本語だったので、あなたが
私が日本語で話すのを見たいのなら、あなたはそれをチェックすることができます
久しぶりに
何人の子供がいますか私には2
人の娘がいます双子の娘は今4
歳半です
ええと大丈夫
です 2つの漢字の
式のルール別の例は、ええと
、私はより多くのルールを2つの漢字に依存しているので、ちょっとバンと一緒に行くことを好み
ます。
フレーズは大丈夫だと言うことです
が、誰かが
私が答えることができる最終的な質問がある場合
は、あなたのフーディー
ファイヤートレッキングファイヤートラックレッドまたはサンセット
オレンジ
がファイヤートラックレッドに間違いなく近い色は何色ですか？
カメラですが、赤い方言に近いです。
ヨーコとドーゲンを書いて、
ジョン・レノンとチャック・ベリーのビデオを見つけました。ちょっと前に
スーパーチャットを逃し
たので、お詫びしました。
もうチャットに登場する
私は
youtubeが
この全体を通して少し不機嫌だった
ので、日本の特定の方言の間に本当に明確な違いはありますか私たちはいつもおさかん方言について聞いて
いますあなたは他の方言を知っていますかそして
いくつかの違いは何ですか もう一つの
良い例は、私はいつも
日本語の単語を忘れますが
、北方言北方言
は、標準的な日本語では声が出ない多くの音に声を加える傾向がある
ので、前に話した
ように イカと言えば行きたいのです
が、アイヌ方言ではないので
、たくさんのk
がgになるので、いいねと言うのではなく、
私はそれが正しいと信じているように
、
あなたが話す方言はもっとたくさんありますあなたは大分に住んでいます
そして大分の人々は
ええと話しますしかし私はええと私はイクガではなくイグーガだと思います
私は日本語の発音を教えてい
ます。そのため、私が常に標準的な日本語を使用するように
することが重要だと思います。私が
常に
標準の日本語を
混ぜるのが好きになり始めたら、
ここでいくつかの方言を言いますか、そこにある方言は
すぐに解体されたようになり
ます。
日本語を教えているのなら、それは良くありません。
なぜなら、それは私の記憶に
ある単語の高低アクセントを適切に参照する能力を制限するから
です。
誰かが行く前に答えられると答えることができますえええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
当然のことながら日本の時間になり
ますが、私の女の子は
隣の部屋で寝ているので、少し静かにする必要があるかもしれ
ませんが、少し静かにできるかもしれません
いつも日本人のことをどう思います
か一般的に言って良いアプローチだと思います。
広島
は非常に似ています。同意するかどうか
はわかりますが、いくつかの類似点があると思いますが
、かなり大きな違いもあると理解しています。
同様に
、いくつかの点ではい、いくつかの点で、
大丈夫、
ええと、あなたの好きな過小評価された日本食は何ですか。
何もないよりは
ましですが、シャドウイングしているときに自分自身を録音してから
、ネイティブ
スピーカーまたはページアクセントについてよく知っている人にシャドウイング
を確認してもらうと、シャドウ
イングする方がさらに良いです。 シャドウを
録音にダウイング
して、実際に正しい発音でシャドウイングしていることを確認し
ます。多くの場合、最初は
シャドウイングを行っていて、
ピッチの動作や研究を始めたばかりのときに
、正しいピッチのアクセントでシャドウイングしていると思い
ますが、
特に
ネイティブのフィードバックを得ることができれば、事実を振り返るその2番目のステップは実際にはそれほど多くありません私
はそれがさらに良いと思います
金原シーモア
スーパーチャット
が好きです
ネイティブオーストラリアの日本語のアクセントまたはイギリスの
アクセント
はい私はそうそうええと、ネイティブの
日本人の
場合
、英国で生まれ育った人、またはオーストラリアで生まれ育っ
た人がアクセント付きの日本語を話している場合は、
それらの場所から来るアクセントをほとんど使わずに話す人もいますが、
一般的に言えば、
私はさまざまな人のアクセントの違いを聞くことができ
ます。 多くのアメリカ人
が苦労しているrの音のように、私は確かに非常にアメリカ的です。
ええと、
私はからの友人がいました。
留学中に隣に住んでいた
イギリス
のおっと、彼の日本語でイギリス英語が聞こえたと思います。彼
は私の日本語でアメリカ英語を
聞く
ことができたと思います。
[音楽]
デュアルサウンドとUサウンドに問題があり
ます。コースでそれらを詳細に分解します。また、
以下の説明にリンクされ
ています。これは、現時点では実際には答えられませ
んが
、コナーは常に下向きのピッチです。
しかし、私はrの音を
詳細に
分析し
ます。もしあなたがもっと大丈夫な人を学ぶことに興味があるなら、私はあなたが
子鹿を出てきたみんなのおかげでええと、
あなたが まだwatc 来てくれてありがとう。
また、
夏に立ち寄ってくれてありがとう。
特に
日本人の皆さん
、夏のチャンネルをチェックして
みてください。 彼女のチャンネルは
すぐそこにリンクさ
れています彼女は彼女の名前の横にチェックがあります
夏との
素晴らしいチャンネルコラボレーションがすぐ
に来るので
大丈夫
です だから私は
あなたたちと何度も何度も話します
多分エルデンリングストリーム多分
今夜遅く多分明日私達は見るでしょうしかしええとまた
ありがとうそしてあなたたちにすぐに会いましょう
[音楽]
外国人